it's a lot of people from the Midwest
that had never encountered anything so
they just assumed that I'm black yeah
they think you're black kind of looks
like the Jesse Williams I think yeah
when he came in here he said he boxes
are you good at boxing is not just like
fighting I was like he might be Mexican
bro
brian's toys watch her back are you
Asian at all
listen man this is a great set I like
what you're doing here oh he built it
he's Mexican yeah he's Mexican
what contractor did this bro
the tiny meat gang I thought that Cody
was Asian too it's so hacky no I thought
you were Cody KO because that just
sounded like a more Asian name
any idea that Vietnamese people have Co
it's like the last name
you're a gang like let's go
you might have said it oh
she said a lot though